[Applause]
foreign
I get it I do the same thing if I were
seated there
happy Wednesday everybody it's almost
Christmas which means I better start
that batch of cookies for Santa before
it's too late
or before Larry Kudlow buys up all the
butter
it's weird he doesn't even bake
so let's talk about language on Monday
Stanford University the poor man's Chico
State
published a language guide which quote
aims to eliminate harmful language
including racist violent and biased
language this is redundant in Stanford
websites and code of course they ignore
the most harmful words of all your
tuition for this will be 60 Grand a year
the bad words came in several categories
like ableists culturally appropriative
gender-based imprecise language and
institutionalized racism thankfully
there's nothing in there about knock
knock jokes
like this one Knock Knock
You Stanford
so
that's one swear word
so under the ableist category instead of
using Basket Case say nervous apparently
Basket Case once referred to a limitless
person who must be carried around in a
basket
I didn't know that and I funny I see
myself as a basket case
well since I commute in one on Bill
hemmer's bicycle
instead of walk-in hours say open hours
to be more inclusive with to those with
disabilities of course they didn't
factor in this man's feelings
get it
walk in Walk In For Walking
solid thank you
under imprecise language instead of
using the term American say U.S citizen
that's because American implies the U.S
is the most important country in the
Americas when we all know it's really
Canada
but even U.S citizens that'll be
imprecise by the time Biden's done half
the people in America won't be one
yeah red meat yum yum
instead of Karen use demanding or
entitled white woman
[Applause]
it's worth but
a form of institutionalized racism I
mean imagine if it were reversed instead
of saying Maxine you say demanding or
entitled black woman
you'd be canceled faster than a Chris
Wallace talk show
never over yeah
don't say straight say heterosexual
because it implies anyone who's gay is
bent and therefore not normal
especially if they have Peyronie's
disease
I never should have tried to hop that
fire hydrant in 1989
but now they have great drugs
they say
Universal's on Fox all the time they
show a bent banana people know what I'm
[Laughter]
Banana's already bent Greg
they say to swap peanut gallery with
audience or hecklers or critics instead
because the term refers to cheap seats
in theaters where black sat during the
Vaudeville era
it's true but George Washington Carver
also made the peanut popular worldwide
but hey Stanford thanks for bringing up
something that most black or white
people didn't even know was racist and
then giving us something else to fight
about 90 years later thank you so much
that's okay
I don't need the Applause I'm healthy
don't say Thug say suspect or criminal
because that's racist and thugs have
feelings even as they mug you
hell let's just start calling him
gentlemen did you see that gentleman
Sucker Punch that 80 year old Asian lady
I hope that gentleman doesn't rape again
once they let him out
you happy now Stanford speaking of
racism no more browned bag just say
lunch and learn so now you can't call
Brown things Brown like a bag or a suit
or your hair or do I have to refer to my
shoes as lunch colored
which which they are when I get too
drunk
I wonder if Hefty will have to change
the name of their bags
Hefty I mean think about who that
offends
[Laughter]
Hefty Hefty Hefty
remember that black sheep is out to be
replaced by Outkast which is great if
you're in the Taliban it's less
embarrassing to say you're screwing an
outcast
also you got to replace gangbusters with
very successful because even MS-13 needs
a safe space
and instead of calling someone Chief why
not just use their name
so like instead of saying how you doing
Chief just say hello miss Warren
probably should end there but I won't
you're not supposed to say preferred
pronouns it's just pronouns because
preferred implies that non-binary gender
is a preference so now it's not a
preference so we're back to being born
that way but then if you're born that
way why would you use surgery to undo
how you were physically and healthily
born
at least you can see your biology with
your eyes
I'm thinking the pronoun for whoever
made these rules is dumbass
instead of ballsy you say bold or risk
taker how ironic in that changing ballsy
is exactly the opposite of being bold
it's language castration and Stanford is
now the place for eunuchs
finally another word Stanford doesn't
like stupid instead say boring or uncool
but I prefer saying Stanford
let's welcome tonight yes
she's so blunt that Snoop tried to smoke
her daddy's corner on SiriusXM Patriot
Senate job centered
he runs up the score on liberal boards
co-host of Fox and Friends Weekend will
cave
her ideas are so bright you can use them
as Christmas lights financial analyst
Heather
foreign
you'll have to replace the drywall my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyron
Sonny welcome back to the show happy
holidays Merry Christmas Merry Christmas
to you I'm reclaiming you're reclaiming
good for you do you think this this
attempt at kind of like removing words
is a sincere effort or there's something
else going on something nefarious if you
will no I'm gonna go I'm going to be
revolutionary here and say it's white
supremacy yeah that's all it is like
when you look at it and you say uh it's
institutionalized speech right and then
you look at uh who started it and when
they're starting to say grammar is
racist uh learning proper English is
racist well the people that started the
institutionalized racism also made that
grammar so I'm thinking all of it is
racist so I don't have to play by any of
your damn rules yeah so I'm not gonna
I'm gonna um you know drop the G's off
my word I like to ask for a drink of
water instead of ask
um you know you know just anything I can
do to Buck the system to really stick it
to white supremacy and let them know
they can't control my language that's
really good you know what I think I'm
going to become an Ask murderer see
there you go we can all meet it we can
all meet at the library and we can
figure it out
but if they get you got to think about
it like the the people that uh created
institutionalized racism in the terms of
grammar are now also the people that get
to change the grammar at which point do
you lose your power if you [ __ ] up the
first time why are we gonna give you a
second time to go back and redo the
words no you you had your chance when
you had your chance it became
institutionalized racism so I'm gonna
fight white supremacy and not listen to
you there you go all right Sonny
well
you know that you can't say beating a
dead horse which raises the question how
will the horse know it's dead
and I would prefer that you beat
something dead why can't you say beating
a dead horse because I think it it's
like it implies animal cruelty wow the
categories are really broad did you say
Broad
thank you thank you you are the secret
sexist thank you no it's a learning
moment for me yeah I appreciate you
educating I hope that you absorb this
teachable moment and bring it back to
the racist at Fox and Friends Weekend
I can't speak for the two ladies
our age and w-o-m-y-n our age of vintage
Tyrus Greg remember the movie Boomerang
Eddie Murphy Martin Lawrence in that
movie Martin Lawrence played Eddie
Murphy's crazy everything is racist
conspiracy theory friend do you remember
yeah and there's a scene when they're at
the pool hall and he says I see it now
you see the game the the the pool table
is green like the earth and the game is
for the white ball to knock off all of
the colored balls and you don't win the
game until you take out the black ball
word
and everybody goes wow and he's their
crazy friend now he would have a
doctoral thesis at Stanford he'd be a
contributing Rider at the Atlantic and
he would give abramex kindy a run for
his money as a bestseller that's true
but you know what that is not that seems
pretty sensible to me
this is white supremacy yeah the black
ball will have to get knocked first
because if the black ball wasn't given
preferential treatment then you're back
to white supremacy that's true
and then the the end result is you got
some buddies balls in your pocket
Joe uh Heather welcome back it's been
like a dog's age can I say that
check the list I know a canine's uh age
I'm sorry um I what drives me crazy
about this is a lot of this stuff if you
didn't know about about it it wouldn't
matter like I didn't know like I didn't
never heard about Basket Case Basket
Case to me is somebody who's so ner I'm
a basket case like I I'm neurotic all
the time I had no idea I meant somebody
was being carried around in a basket now
I'm bothered by that image well I
actually it was probably the only one
that read through all I think there were
13 pages of words they had crazy insane
no but you have like a short synopsis
version
um the word insane will you just said
referred to us as ladies that has also
been banned any gender term was banned
by Stanford it's only gender neutral
terms now I can't figure out what you
would replace prisoner and prostitute
with that that wasn't in your free
citizens
um
but you when I was reading through the
13-page dictionary of banned words I
thought this extends outside of the
educational institutions into the
corporate world as well and all these
companies the HR uh divisions are making
all of these policies to cover their
butts from lawsuits from the PC police
you look at what happened with Disney
and and the impact of them jumping on
the woke bandwagon alienating a bunch of
their customers now you look at Elon
Musk although I agree with what he's
doing being a free speech Advocate and
getting involved in politics or any of
this woke type of stuff really get you
in trouble he's lost a ton of money I
mean you may be on his level Now Greg oh
thank you type of income so it's a bad
business decision I think for the
corporate world it's expanded
unfortunately outside of an Ivy League
institution which you'd expect from
there you go uh Tyrus I'm not sure we
can say alienating
it oh
first of all it took 18 months
to do this yeah and a team of scientists
so
to Will's point he's right the the
idiots are running the show with titles
now the the term that really bothered me
the name that they well first of all the
American thing kiss my ass it's America
but the thing that really bothered me
was they wanted to get rid of the word
grandfather right
and their explanation was absolutely
ridiculous because as a black man to
make it to be grandfather is a big deal
and to have children to grandfathered
around that you helped raise is a big
deal I'm going to be grandfather I might
even put some extra on it I might just
be grand Papa I don't know but I'm going
to be grand and I'm going to be
celebrated
and I don't to my kids when you start
procreating no ties I want good gifts
but it just this is the dumbing down of
society luckily you know we don't go to
Stanford yeah so I would take your sixty
thousand dollars and and start looking
at some really good division two schools
some trade schools
DeVry University of Phoenix is beautiful
this time of year
Perfect all right but uh yeah when when
they started when they started telling
you what you can and cannot say it's
time to not go to that school it's time
to run away hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else